un sombre retour d'europe pour joe biden
après la défaite en virginie
nous avons gagné lance le gouverneur élu
glen yankees
une victoire qui redonne de l'élan aux
républicains après avoir été boudé
pendant 11 ans virginie l'année dernière
encore les démocrates avaient remporté
l'état avec dix points d'avancé
aux et les démocrates gagne de justesse
en virginie c'est un échec cuisant pour
le candidat et ancien gouverneur termine
qu'en neuf mais aussi pour joe biden qui
était venu faire campagne avec lui
cette défaite est perçu comme un
avertissement aux démocrates qui
pourrait perdre les deux chambres lors
des élections de mi-mandat de 2022 et le
spectre de dans notre championnat jamais
bien loin
avec 2 mais
les démocrates vont devoir se réveiller
17 partisane du parti ils ont besoin
d'être un peu plus unis et arrêté d'être
négatif est divisée
c'était il ya un an l'heure était aux
célébrations avec la victoire de jo
weiden il parlait de la bataille pour
l'âme de l'amérique et se présenter
comme un rassembleur un homme de
compromis qui veut réconcilier les
américains le pays respirer ne vais plus
au rythme des truites enflammé de dans
notre chambre ne peut provoquer de
graves un an plus tard joe biden n'aura
pas réussi son pari il ne sera pas
parvenu à unir son parti et encore moins
le pays
pourtant les démocrates contrôlent le
sénat et la chambre des représentants
mais le congrès est paralysé à doullens
powering dame j'ai compris que les gens
voulaient des résultats reconnus joe
biden aujourd'hui car les démocrates
restent divisés sur deux gros projets de
loi l'infrastructure et le big bag
valeurs qui comprend les réformes
sociales et l'environnement homme
de gauche il a l'occasion de faire de
bonnes choses dit ce texan conservateur
mais il va falloir qu'ils aient des
résultats
pourtant joe biden vivait une lune de
miel lors de ses 100 premiers jours il
revient aux accords de paris les médias
ne sont plus les ennemis du peuple il
fait également adopter son plan de
sauvetage de 1900 milliards de dollars
sur la pandémie shannon price un vaccin
dans le bras et de l'argent dans les
poches des américains disent utile 200
millions d'américains sont alors déjà
vaccinées puis les choses commencent à
se gâter leur très chaotique des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
les milliers de réfugiés à la frontière
mexicaine et puis l'inflation était sur
ces questions économiques et sociales
que les électeurs en virginie ont voté
préoccupé par l'augmentation du coût de
la vie la stratégie des démocrates a été
de faire une campagne anti tschopp qui
était finalement déconnecté de la
réalité des électeurs ici assez beau de
l'eger glissera du canada à washington